[Music]
this morning on social media women all
over
china are dismissing a new government
policy on the size of families
all married couples are now allowed to
have three children
instead of two but amnesty international
says the increased limit is still a
great violation of women's sexual and
reproductive rights
remy innocencio looks now at the chinese
government's move
to increase the country's population
after decades of tight restrictions
china needs more babies yes that may
seem
like a strange thing to say since it's
the world's most populous country
with 1.4 billion people but china is
getting older
faster and beijing expects deaths will
outnumber births as early as next year
fewer people mean less consumption which
means slower economic growth
that's a threat to stability for the
communist party but beijing's new policy
declaring couples can have three
children
up from two isn't enough says political
scientist jean-pierre kavistan
in hong kong unless the government
introduces
real incentives providing special
allowances
to couples who have three children i
don't think that chinese couples are
going to have more kids
a recent study out of china shows money
is the biggest worry with child care
concerned second
in 1980 beijing embarked on its
controversial one-child policy to
control its then skyrocketing population
considered sound at the time most
chinese appear
to have gotten used to it this week on
chinese social media
memes of triple bunk beds went viral and
this cartoon with a person
having to choose between triplets and
life
women in china were vocal there should
be more policy support
more education support and medical
support ju hong yan says
men could do more i don't want to have a
second child
a third is even more impossible says
this mother of one
and one more population point to
consider there are people being born
right now who could see a world where
china is
no longer the most populous country by
the year 2100 and yes it is coming
the british medical journal the lancet
says that india could take the number
one spot followed by nigeria
and then china in number four the united
states
for cbs this morning raymie in asensio
hong kong
pretty interesting reaction from the
chinese there huh a lot of people can
relate to the men can do more
yes i love the world the look on the
kid's face said it all